when the kovid lockdown hit in 2020 many
families struggled for darren work as a
scaffolder dried up and he turned to
stealing scrap metal to make money but
he paid the ultimate price suffering
life-changing third-degree burns this is
his story and a warning it does have
pictures and a description of his
injuries
darren thanks so much for coming to talk
to us today really appreciate it it's
really good to see you
um
before we get into the story about what
happened to you
18 months ago can we talk a bit about
your life before 2020
your school
apprenticeship you became a scaffolder
can you tell me about that yeah
basically in high school and i was in
construction and then i went off to
do a plastering course around two years
and then halfway through just about 18
months two years mark i went i changed
my trade from plastering to scaffolding
and then become i've done six months
training course and then engaged with a
part one and then part two i was a fully
qualified scaffolder
and basically that's
what brought me up to the obviously
being a scaffolder and then
2020 comes and lockdown
comes yep and works slowed down
for you
what happened did you get furlough from
the government what happened with your
financial circumstances my financial
struggles were um i wasn't up to date
with my tax returns right and so i
didn't get any help with a
self-employment grant or get any
furlough so i was basically throughout
the lockdown period i was struggling
financially for funds um all the
building sites and everything was shut
yeah so i wasn't able to even find work
let alone commence any work so i was
just really in a struggle with it let's
talk about what happened you said
previously that as a younger man in the
past you had broken the law here and
there yeah but you left that behind
right yeah so obviously in the younger
days when i'm struggling for money i
used to help myself to a bit of scrap
out of old abandoned buildings like
places that were getting demolished and
ready for demolition so i wasn't like
harming anybody i wasn't doing anything
majorly wrong in my mind just explain to
us what it what is scrapping because
some people where
basically basically if you've got an old
abandoned building that's getting pulled
down and demolitioned don't demolish so
yeah um i would say wouldn't have been
on the building sites before the site
agent said to me i said oh there's a
load of lead on there if you want to
help yourself trick it's only going to
go in the reef cycle inside so that's
where i start picked up from being a
worker being granted access to scrap
from the site that was working on by the
site manager so so they sort of
introduced me into it by saying helps
out to this because other people are
doing it so obviously i've picked that
up it's something i shouldn't have
picked up but obviously i picked it up
and when november 2021 had my initial
accident i made a bad judgment of error
so do you got
just before we go into that had you got
in trouble with the police about that in
the past when you're a younger man there
absolutely one or two times where i've
gotten a little bit of trouble and then
you stop doing it yeah carried on with
work yeah trying to scaffold maintain my
career
lockdown happens and then
yeah you're desperate for cash yeah so i
had no choice in order to go back to
that sort of line of work and um and and
tell us what happened that night what
happened to you um basically i was in an
old abandoned place i believe it's some
sort of steel works i believe um
and i was
doing what i was doing collecting what i
could find sort of off the ground and
stuff like that and then um there was
like a bit of an electrical control room
um and obviously
i've seen the doors wide open and stuff
so i'll just add a bit of a nose there
and then there's like copper bars inside
the actual machine but because of the
way the land was situated i'll be
like disused and the fence and
everything was open and anyone who could
just walk on and off there i just
presumed it was off because i didn't see
no lights i didn't hear no noises
uh the doors were wide open so it's just
like
just i don't know it's just i just
presumed it was off and i could sort of
help myself to obviously a bit of extra
cash yeah
and within a blink of an eye i felt my
body lock up like an initial like i
don't know a character i can't find the
words to explain it but then i basically
switched off like i don't remember
anything else apart from obviously dying
i believe i was dead for around two
minutes so maybe a short period of time
but obviously all of a sudden i just
woke up and then started running for my
life and i hear him remember you're on
fire yeah falling on fire so on my
stomach all my clothes had three layers
of clothing on so after the arc flash
explosion all my clothes was on fire but
at this time of being in the room i
don't remember i don't just like i
remember vaguely watching my funeral
take place as stuffed as it sounds some
people don't believe me but i it's what
i remember um so obviously i've run out
for my life um i'm on fire i've
obviously would be adrenaline i was able
to run faster than the two of the lads
so i should have stopped really and let
him put me out but obviously i was more
concerned about getting to the main road
for safety
so
i got to the main road
and as my friend was on the phone to the
ambulance service so they had about 26
minute wait time
um and literally within seconds of him
being on the phone an ambulance was
passing with the blue lights on and i've
run from the car park bit where i was in
obviously in a bad way um and to put
myself in front of the ambulance and
darn you you went to hospital you went
to the queen elizabeth hospital in
birmingham um
what happened there can i think we have
some photos actually which you're okay
if we share aren't you that's um around
december i believe
and obviously afterwards i got a disease
called folliculitis dervicans where i
lost more hair than that so as you can
see i've had my full face completely
ripped off and reading off the skin off
my legs
i think the only
bit of normal skin that i managed to
keep was probably four or five inches on
the back of my neck so everything from
that point here all the way around my
neck my face and obviously arms up to
the shoulder and on my stomach was
completely wrapped in that btm material
from that image there to you today you
look remarkably wow yeah i've come a
long way yeah and a lot of people have
said to me said i see burn survivors
struggling for two three years and the
face looks like disfigured and marked
and obviously i don't think i'm not bad
considering it's just obviously what i'm
missing is the features that make a face
so the eyebrows the tip of the nose the
ears and obviously the hairline they're
the main things that build a face and
i've lost every single one of them um
and just in terms of you're in hospital
you woke up
you were in a in coma for
23 days 27 days 27 days
when you were scrapping you obviously
didn't realize the implications of what
could happen no obviously yeah i just i
wasn't fully aware of the dangers um
and like i said obviously the doors was
open on the room that i entered
um so it's just it's just a major bad
judgment of error all around what
happened with you all with the police or
nothing um the west midlands uh police
service they sent police officers to me
address where i was living in manchester
at the time where i used to live with
mum um the i was out at the mall at the
time but they asked if they've had
life-changing injuries
so obviously you explained to him said
yeah as he's had our list done not done
soon so obviously my sort of mind i've
had my punishment in a sense now i've
got the rest of my life to live with it
it must be extremely mentally difficult
for you what keeps you get what keeps
you going um
what keeps me going i'd probably
narrow it down to
b i've been blessed with a second chance
at life because
i believe for someone so like it's a
miracle to survive it so what's the
story behind that miracle for surviving
such a significant injury because like i
said i've had the worst possible injury
the human body could possibly withstand
have suffered being electrocuted and
i've had an arc slash blast sent me
catapulting across the room and i've
suffered a lot of inhalation damage due
to the smoke uh a gas charge and
fragments of metal oil just ripping me
to bits and
i just i believe it's a miracle that
they've managed to give me a second
chance at life so that's my main i don't
know i just believe it's there's a
reason and there's a purpose for me to
be here because if there wasn't it would
have took me but it didn't take me so
you have had suicidal thoughts yeah i've
been i've been to the worst of suicide
recently and because of something keeps
stopping me and i'm always forever
grateful for all the surgeons who are
involved saving life elizabeth and
you're a walking miracle yeah and
obviously early aftercare because of
that i just i feel like i have to do
something constructive with it instead
of sitting at home not doing anything
about it i want to be like a bit of an
inspiration to others out there who are
in a crisis so i can to sort of
basically can look at me because i had a
comment of someone someone put comment
on one of my pictures or videos are done
with their
uh online and they said um i've been
overweight and i've struggled with
mental health for many years but after
reading your story and hearing what
you've got what you've been through
um it's made me realize to pull my socks
up because in a sense obviously if i if
i can go through this
then other people with no actual
injuries on the outside but they're
mentally unwell they need to look at
someone like me and think i'm going to
run it if you can go to the brink and
come back and find light at the end of
the tunnel then why can't i i read that
you wanted to you're thinking about
whether you become a motivational
speaker do you go to talk to kids in
school
thinking about
crime i wanna i wanna i wanna make
awareness of anyone who's doing this
sort of thing like scrapping business
and not awares of the dangers i want to
make him aware of the dangers and i want
to educate him to nip it in the bud and
never to do this because not many people
get given a chance and i want them
people in a struggle financially doing
yourself thing go to college train
yourself get educated and get a good
career i mean how are you managing
though in terms of
you know we've talked a lot about the
cost of living crisis prices going on
how are you how are you managing or do
you uh just about just about managed
i've got a bit of family and support
about me but it is difficult it's a lot
obviously the money that i'm on at the
moment with benefits and stuff it's a
hell of a lot less than what i was
earning working
by a quarter
do you know what i mean so obviously
it's difficult but i've always i've just
have to manage with what i've got and
live with what i've got and find another
and also find
a new career if you like you know you
can find
i'm still relatively young and 29 and 13
october so be ashamed for me to sit away
and waste my life and just do nothing
and then cause pain for other people and
all sorts like i wanna i wanna do
something constructive and be an
inspiration to others that's what i want
to do
because i've still got my mind like even
though the appearance has changed your
body though yeah my heart's still
beating i'm still the same person as
what i was before
and
i just look different
and is that hard
looking different yeah because i i think
you look great
you look really well i do considering
what i've been through well this is that
very hard
to look in the mirror yeah because you
know what you did look like yeah so
obviously in my eyes what hurts the most
is obviously the face that i was born
with on the face that everybody knew me
as darren has gone and it's never coming
back and it's no matter what i do in the
world that face will never come back so
what people remember me what as is gone
and it's really disturbing to think of
that as well and it hasn't been
it's not been very long it's been 18
months so actually too as i look now
this is the worst i'll ever look um i've
not had any reconstructive surgery yet
i've not had my marker related eyebrows
on me hair transplant uh well the main
thing i'm going for at the moment is bio
printing bioprinting technologies so
there's three ways of reconstructing an
a you can have magnetic clip-ons
like a silicone or you can have uh rib
reconstruction where they tamper away at
your ribs and rebuild the cartilage out
of the air out your ribside but then
you're relying on the surgeon's
technique to sculpture the air but
there's a third option which just come
out relatively new
at swansea university and a few other
companies in the world like australia
and china are doing it so basically take
your stem cells from your body and they
put some whatever material with it and
then they can 3d print the cartilage
it's a living ink so they can they can
go on pictures of mule day the
dimensions of how it used to look and
they can they can read they can 3d print
that ear so in time
have you reconstruct your ears to how it
used to look on a picture of my old face
what would you say
uh to young men
to people to people struggling either
with making them ends me struggling with
how they look how they feel about
themselves struggling with depression
what's your
what's your message
my message to anyone out there
attempting this sort of thing
is to don't even contemplate doing it
because one it's not worth it you can
get into trouble and get in prison for
it
two if you do do it and you could end up
dead or you could end up looking like me
and having even more problems because
even though i was in a financial
struggle and i had my own issues going
on before the accident since the
accident all my problems have multiplied
by thousands so i don't i would what
i've been through i wouldn't wish this
on my worst enemy i just wouldn't and
darren finally when you look back on
that day just before you went into that
yard what would you what would you say
to yourself now
do you turn and walk away
but i can't turn the clock back
do you know what i mean that is
something if you had a stopwatch to stop
go back in time i'd love to do that but
obviously i can't physically do that i
can't change the matter of time
but alls i can do is the time that i've
got left in my life and what the next
journey in the next chapter in life is
to do better and do well from it well
i'm sure you will and thank you so much
for coming and telling us your story
today i really liked meeting you i
really enjoyed it
thank you very much